Als hätte die atomindustrie unserem planeten nicht genug vermüllte soll ein schwimmendes
atomkraftwerk den strahlenden müll wohl über den ganzen planeten verteilt ich gebe zu
dass das polemisch ist aber ich finde es echt zu treffen das video ist übrigens in zusammenarbeit mit technology review
entstanden und am ende bekommt er einen gratis heft der wirklich coolen zeitschrift geschenkt ging es ums tanzen fiction herzlich willkommen
Ich finde dass wenn es um gift geht man ruhig polemisch werden darf stickoxide feinstaub
umweltgifte sie alle töten menschen und das ist schlecht man darf das
verurteilen und die gefahren beim namen nennen und das gilt auch für die kernkraft spätestens seit fukushima wissen wir was das für eine
furchtbare solche ist und das dürfen wir auch so sagen atomkraftwerke sind unsicher gefährlich und schicken mit ihrem abfall dem tod in die welt
unbestritten und jetzt kommt's
144 meter lang und 30 meter breit ist der prototyp mit dem namen akademik lomonossow
eines schwimmenden
atomkraftwerks zwei reaktionen mit jeweils 35 megawatt elektrischer leistung finden auf dem schwimmenden
kernkraftwerk platz rein rechnerisch könnte damit eine stadt mit
200.000 einwohnern mit strom versorgt werden spannend vor allem für entlegene regionen dieser welt als äußerst riskant
bezeichnen kritiker und kritikerinnen das ganze projekt die befürworter dagegen verweisen auf die weltweite nachfrage und bezeichnen die schwimmenden atomkraftwerke als
klimafreundliche alternative zur kohle im mai wurde die akademik lomonossow im hafen von st petersburg der öffentlichkeit
präsentiert ende juli begann die beladung des schwimmenden
atomkraftwerks im moment das war in sankt petersburg an massiven bürgerprotesten gescheitert mit diesem schritt steht fest eine neue art der
dezentralen energieversorgung ist möglich wenn er mich fragt ist das eine äußerst fragwürdige
entwicklung in den zeiten in denen die meisten anderen länder
atomkraftwerke stilllegen doch die technologie dafür ist nicht neu schon seit vielen jahren nämlich tragen u-boote eisbrecher und flugzeugträger kleine
kernreaktoren durch die meere hinter dem prototypen akademik lomonossow steckt die russische atomenergie agentur rosatom
ihr plan ist es vor allem entlegene regionen durch das schwimmende atomkraftwerk mit strom zu versorgen
zu der elektrischen leistung von 35 megawatt der beiden reaktoren kommt noch eine thermische leistung von etwa
150 megawatt im kommenden jahr soll die akademik lomonossow
nach per weggeschleppt werden das ist eine nautische
siedlung etwa 350 kilometer nördlich des polarkreises
gelegen lautet seine mission die russische bohrinseln mit strom zu versorgen
ebenso wie die 5000 einwohner und zwar sowohl mit strom als auch mit wärme
der langfristige plan der russen ist aber somit an die großen gas und ölvorkommen in der aktiven region zu kommen kein
wirklich einfaches vorhaben denn in den entsprechenden regionen kann es durchaus mal
bis zu minus 60 grad celsius werden sprich je geht es gar nicht um klimaneutrale energieversorgung
sondern genau um das gegenteil
ziemlich pervers das ganze direktoren bestehen aus brennstäben mit niedrig angereichertem uran die zu 20 prozent aus uran
235 anteil bestehen mit den
druckwasserreaktoren ist man laut rosatom auf der sicheren seite denn diese wurden schon auf den atomeisbrecher
der time klasse erprobt so sollen auch schwere stürme erdbeben der stärke 10 oder
tsunamis dem prototypen nichts anhaben können ein weiterer sicherheitsaspekt
direktorin befinden sich in sicherheitsbehältern die mit wasser geflutet sind in kombination
mit dem pumpen des aktiven kühlsystems soll dadurch im worst case eine kernschmelze verhindert werden
die zirkulation des wassers soll nach angaben von rosatom
aber selbst bei einem ausfall aller kühlpumpen schlimmeres verhindern und die brennstäbe für 24 stunden kühlen doch nicht alle experten
und expertinnen sind davon überzeugt so etwa auch der atom energie experte von greenpeace hans vital ein
atomkraftwerk ohne beton schutzhülle dazu auf einem schwimmenden ponton im stürmischen arktische meer unter widrigsten witterungsbedingungen
dass es wirklich riskant denn das eindämmen einer drohenden kernschmelze
könnte alleine aus logistischen gründen nicht garantiert werden falls ich nämlich der atom ponton bei einem sturm
beispielsweise losreißen würde wäre er ohne eigenen antrieb
manövrierunfähig und was würde im fall eines terroranschlages passieren das russische energieunternehmen
dagegen stützt sich darauf dass die reaktoren
klimafreundlicher sein als die versorgung durch kohle naja aber das hatten wir gerade schließlich würden wir ohne direkten
kohlendioxidausstoß kommen aber dafür verantwortlich sein mehr
treibhaus relevante ressourcen zu fördern und natürlich stecken auch große wirtschaftliche interessen dahinter denn wie eben schon angedeutet könnten solche schwimmenden
atomkraftwerke der strategische schlüssel dafür sein die aktivregion auszubeuten dazu der direktor von rosatom
alexejew wir erwarten großes interesse insbesondere von inselstaaten wo sich die entwicklung einer zentralisierten
energieinfrastruktur schwierig gestaltet und die russischen
atomkraftwerke auf see haben tatsächlich weltweit schon großes interesse ausgelöst beispielsweise bei den ländern argentinien
malaysia und indonesien übrigens sind die russen nicht die einzigen die diese technologie zukünftig
verstärkt einsetzen wollen auch unternehmen aus china und frankreich beispielsweise
tüfteln an diesem konzept bis 2020 will die china general
nuclear power group kleine reaktoren mit 100 megawatt leistung in see stechen lassen und zwar an bord von tanker ähnlichen schiffen
tormann
mehr bleibt da nicht zu sagen vielen dank an technology review in zusammenarbeit mit der redaktion dieser ziemlich coolen zeitschrift ist dieses video entstanden
und exklusiv für dich zum zuschauer habe ich jetzt ein geschenk ihr bekommt nämlich eine ausgabe gratis wenn er auf diesen link hier oben klickt
das lohnt sich so richtig da sind noch mehr hammer themen drin und hier geht es weiter dafür auch draufklicken
thorium reaktoren die lösung aller energieprobleme mit atomkraft bis dann
bleibt dran